there's a good reason this animal called
a tarsier looks like a koala with a bad
meth habit you see this critter hunts at
night but it has the wrong kind of eyes
for seeing in a dark you know that glow
you get when you shine a light at a
cat's eyes
it's a tissue called the tepee dome
lucidum that acts like a mirror to
collect more light in the darkness it's
one of the things that makes cats such
effective nighttime predators so yeah
the tarsier doesn't happen instead it's
oversized eyes suck in more light no
mirrors acquired I'm talking really
oversized the Tarsus peepers are so
enormous it can't move them so if it
wants to see something off to the side
it has to swivel its head around like an
owl a tweaking owl somehow the tarsier
makes it work the critter is small
enough to fit in the palm of your hand
but it can leap 15 feet it jumps from
tree to tree snagging insects as it goes
the tarsier can manage those jumps
because it has elongated feet and ankle
bones together they're called the Tarsus
hence the animals name or we can go by
my name for it staring the crude eyes
what is there something in my teeth
dude why you looking at me like that all
right
Meowth that's enough thank you